all right so there's part a part b let's
go back to the question and see what
it's asking us it says
how far correct to the nearest meter
does the boat
eventually travel as it comes to a stop
how far does it go um eventually as it
comes to a stop now it's probably worth
mentioning
that this phrase you know comes to a
stop is what happens in reality the boat
does stop
um but the actual model that we've
created an exponential decay model
the model is so as the question itself
says greatly simplified
an exponential decay model like it never
gets down to
velocity equals zero you've got this
asymptotic behavior right
so that's the whole issue with using
like a perfect mathematical model
even though we've been ignoring
resistance before and now we're
including it
still there are things that are being
left out but that's okay we can still
use this model
nonetheless how do we work this out what
i'm going to do is come back to
this set of equations here and what i'm
trying to do is to
solve for well let me just go back to
the question sorry
i'm solving for how far how far um that
is a question of
displacement right so that's a question
about x i'm trying to solve for x my
final line will be x
equals something or other right and the
way that i will know
what x i'm after is when the boat
eventually comes to a stop that's a
velocity
of zero now we know velocity never
actually equals zero
but i have a calculus trick in my pocket
that helps me work out
as things approach something even if
they never quite get there
and that is of course limits right so
i'm going to take the limit as v
approaches 0.
but the limit as v approaches 0 of what
go and have a look back through all of
our equations which one is going to be
the most
useful um is it going to be this
equation here that we just finished part
a with
there's no problem using it but i don't
think it's the easiest one to use
because
i want an x equals right the whole point
of all of these lines of working like
these whatever 10 15 lines of working
was to get to a v equals so i'm going to
backtrack through
all of my equations and i want you to
have a think through your own working
which one of these equations is the
easiest to use
to solve for an x equals something or
other let me just
pause for a minute let me see if you can
work out which one might be the most
suitable
and where i'm going to go
having given you a brief moment to think
is i'm going to go to
this equation right here in fact it's so
important i'm going to give it a name
i'm going to call it 1a
why is this equation useful well number
one it is actually the equation between
x
and v with the constant actually
evaluated so that's kind of important i
don't really want to go
much further past back up that way
because i'm going to need to evaluate c
again right no point doing that
and this equation here as soon as i go
to the next line you can see that x term
which i'm after i want an x equals
it goes up into the exponent of this
exponential right and so it's like oh
it's harder to get to not easier to get
to
so even though this line here i'm
calling it equation 1a
even though it doesn't have like a kind
of slam dunk x equals
um it's got it sort of separated out in
a fairly easy fashion it's not
it's not difficult to make x the subject
from that equation so that's what i'm
going to do
so from picking up from 1a
the first thing i will do is i'm going
to subtract
log of 56 from both sides so i'll put
this
x term on the left because that's where
i want it in the end
and that leaves me with this is what
used to be on the left hand side so now
it's on the right
and i'm subtracting log of 56
okay at this point what can i do well
a couple of different things couple
different choices in my brain the first
thing that's going to be useful is
in much the same way that from this line
to this line
i broke apart this single exponential
term
into two exponential terms in much the
same way but in reverse i'm going to
take these two log terms and combine
them
into one log term so i can write
log of do some nice big fat brackets
here
think about when you're subtracting log
terms go back to you know all your
logarithmic laws that you learnt
when you're subtracting logs that is
equivalent to
division of the two things inside the
argument i guess you could say so that's
1 plus 10
v and that's a 56 on the inside there on
the denominator
okay and that's minus x over 10.
at this point i'm pretty much ready to
go to make x the subject
i'm going to multiply both sides both by
-10 so that gives me -10 here
log of same thing
nothing's changed there one more thing
before i then try and
pull some limits on this right another
log law see that minus
out the front there the power law for
logs tells me that that minus one i
could bring it inside and make it the
power up the front
or up the top rather of what's on the
inside of the log term so this could be
all raised to the power of negative one
and you guys know what raising something
to the power of negative one does it
takes the reciprocal so
i'm going to write whoopsie daisy that
10 is still out the front there
that log remains
unchanged but i'm going to flip upside
down
this using my logos
okay and now lastly we said uh you know
what we want to
do is work out what's happening as the
velocity tends towards zero as it comes
to a stop
so i'm gonna write the limit as v
approaches
zero if you wanted to be really fancy
fancy schmancy technical
we would say zero approach from the
right hand side because what we're doing
is
where um so you put a plus there because
we're approaching it from positive
values coming down because we don't know
what happens from negative values
being that my boat was never travelling
backwards as far as i know anyway
so the limit is being applied to x over
on the right hand side
because that v in there there's actually
no problem with treating it as if it
were actually zero
you can see what i'm going to get is log
of 56
over 1 plus 0. last i checked 1 plus 0
is 1. so 56 over 1 just gives me 56.
like so 10 log 56 and if you reach for
your calculator
go ahead and do that and um give me some
decimal places pop them into the chat
maybe give me um
three or four decimal places and let's
see if you get a reasonable answer out
of this
looking for some
calculator work
okay fantastic yeah i got 40.25
something or other and the question was
to the nearest meter so as charm and
suzy have pointed out we can round that
so i'm going to say therefore
approximately the boat comes to a stop
approximately 40 meters
after the
finish line that's my interpretation and
me answering
a word question with words
so i hope that makes sense to you in
some ways even though it is this sort of
other category of thinking resisted
motion
we can kind of treat these equations
just like we have any other
equations to do with forces it's just
that the particular forces that you get
have this particular behavior whereby
the greater the velocity is the greater
the
force that will be acting back on you so
the example that we just had a look at
and the examples you're going to see
when you go onto the calendar and you
can see the questions that have been
assigned
they're all to do with this kind of
situation where
like cyclists and swimmers we're dealing
with
um motion that is being resisted
or motion that's in a horizontal
direction and therefore being resisted
in a horizontal direction it will be
sometimes things like this aerodynamic
drag or a friction force like traveling
along the ground
we are going to wait until friday to
introduce motion that's not
horizontal but vertical so there's going
to be vertical
resistance but also you've got to make
that play with gravity and things like
that